en compagnie d'hélène phrase bien sûr
pour jour hélène ou mangeant damian à la
une de la presse il ya notamment cette
décision d'en parler de la cédéao de
placer le mali sous embargo pour
sanctionner la junte au pouvoir d'après
wac et sert à ces mesures radicales sera
lié au constat d'échec de la cedeao
concernant la transition malienne le
site burkinabè s'inquiètent de voir le
mali faire face désormais à une
situation qui pourrait finir d'asphyxié
des populations déjà malmené par les
attaques terroristes et les conséquences
catastrophiques de l'épidémie de kobe 19
il évoque également le risque dorénavant
de voir le pays se tourner davantage
encore davantage vers la chine et la
russie
frapper fort en espérant que la violence
du coup amène les effrontés à de
meilleures intentions le monde c'était à
lui de la volonté de la cedeao de
circonscrire au plus vite le retour des
militaires sur la scène politique un
phénomène qui touche le mali mais
également la guinée et le tchad et il
s'interroge pour sa part sur la position
de la france pour laquelle cette mise
sous sanction d'un pouvoir avec lequel
elle est en rupture totale peut
apparaître comme une victoire
diplomatique mais la place aussi en
porte à faux comment en effet continuer
à maintenir des opérations avec l'armée
malienne quand la france considère que
ses dirigeants sont engagés dans une
manoeuvre de conservation du pouvoir
diplomatie toujours avec on le disait le
début aujourd'hui à genève de ce sommet
russo américain au sujet de l'ukraine
mais ces discussions laissent sceptiques
damien le figaro qui relève que le
président joe biden a certes menacé son
homologue russe vladimir poutine deux
sanctions comme il n'en a jamais vu je
le cite mais qu'il l'a en réalité que
peu d'atouts en main poutine c'est que
ni washington et ses alliés en europe ne
se battront purpan l'ukraine et les
sanctions économiques ont peu de chance
de le faire plier pronostique le journal
également perplexe damien face à
l'attitude des européens plus dépendant
que jamais du gaz russe minée par leur
dit lyon et qu'il faut de développer une
autonomie stratégique crédible semble de
moins en moins capables de prendre en
main leur sécurité ni même de peser sur
le destin de leur continent
cette impuissance est également
soulignée par le journal suisse le temps
qu'ils demandent à l'union européenne
d'en tirer les leçons en exigeant
d'urgence un dialogue bilatéral avec
moscou en obtenant des états unis d'être
partie prenante des prochaines
discussions et en acceptant de définir
pour de bon à 27 le futur périmètre de
son élargissement et donc de ses futures
frontières que tous ses pays membres
seraient prêts à défendre hélène pour
finir un mot de la campagne pour la
présidentielle en france l'ex ministre
de la justice christiane taubira non sur
l'intention de participer à la primaire
de la gauche mais le scepticisme et la
perplexité gagne cette fois libération
qui s'interroge sur le sens de cette
annonce celle ci on sait intervient
après les refus réitéré de l'écologiste
yannick jadot du jadot du communiste
fabien roussel et du patron des insoumis
jean luc mélenchon de participer à cette
primaire à laquelle la socialiste anne
hidalgo semblait avoir elle aussi
renoncé ce week end ces timbres au lieu
d'analyser la sensation de voir la
gauche enfermé dans le scénario du film
un jour sans fin l'annnonce de
christiane taubira lui apparaissant
comme un coup de poker est une tentative
de passage en force qui ne fait
qu'apporter un peu plus de complexité
dans un jeu déjà passablement compliqué
et ce n'est pas terminé merci beaucoup à
l'âne phrase pour cette revue de presse
et merci à vous d'avoir choisi france 24
on se retrouve dans un quart d'heure
pour un nouveau journal à tout à l'heure
[Musique]